what is the correct or the respectful
way to pronounce
afghanistan afghanistan i
iran iran
so as a russian speaker afghanistan yeah
are the on versus the and yeah is it uh
different country by country as an
english speaker in america
is it pretentious and disrespectful to
say afghanistan
or is it the opposite respectful to say
it that way what are your thoughts on
that that's a fascinating question um
i defer to the
people from those countries to of course
sort out those politics i think
you know one of the fascinating things
about the region broadly is that it is a
place of so many cultures and and it's
really quite cosmopolitan
so i think people are mostly quite
forgiving about how you say
afghanistan afghanistan it's not like
paris
yeah yeah right right the french are not
forgiving no
exactly and i think people are very very
forgiving and i think that
you know iranians are a bit
you know
more instructive in suggesting iran
rather than iran right
iraq
iraq you know i i think there's
there's come to be a fit between
certain ways of pronouncing these places
and
the position that americans take about
them right so
it's more jarring when
people say
iraq
and it comes with
you know a claim that a certain kind of
person you know should be the victim of
violence or
yeah right so yeah it's kind of like
talking about the democratic party or
the democrat party it's uh sometimes
using certain kind of terminology
to make a little bit of a
sort of uh
implied statement about your beliefs
that's fascinating yeah i mean i think
when i hear iraq and iran i mean i think
it yeah is it intentional in the case of
a democrat or is it just a
you know innocent whatever i think again
i think most iranians and afghans people
i know have have been
very cool about that
what
annoys afghans now i can say i think
it's fair to say i don't mean to speak
for
maine's people
people but i can just share with our our
non-afghan friends um
the term afghani
uh is is a kind of term of offense
because that's the name of the currency
and so
a lot of people ask you know why
having especially again it's more
addictive to americans because you know
we've been so deeply involved in that
country obviously for the last 20 years
right so
afghans ask why after 20 years are you
still calling us the wrong name
what is the right name this is somebody
they prefer afghans afghans yeah and and
afghani is the name of the currency and
so i just dodged the book because i was
going to say
yeah that's really great to know yeah
and it's and it's again i think but i
would emphasize that
people are quite open and and you know
it's a
it's a whole region of incredible
diversity and
and respect for
linguistic pluralism actually so i think
that
you know but i also appreciate that
during in this context um when there's a
lot of pain you know in the afghan
diaspora community in particular
you know being called the wrong name
after 20 years when they already feel
so betrayed at this moment you know just
kind of
if one follows us on social media
that is one kind of
hot wire right yeah so the reason i ask
about pronunciation
is because yes it is true that there are
certain things when mispronounced
kind of reveal that you don't care
enough to pronounce correctly that's
right you don't know enough to pronounce
correctly right and you dismiss the
culture and the people which i think
that's right as per your writing is
something that
if it's okay i'll go with afghanistan
just because i'm used to i say iraq iran
but i say afghanistan yeah that's great
is as you do in your writing uh
afghanistan suffers from much
misunderstanding from the rest of the
world
you